This notion of causality is important in debugging
because when you fix a defect we want to make sure to think first.
We want to make sure that the defect is actually error, that is it is wrong.
We also want to make sure that the defect causes the failure if A is the defect and B is the failure.
We want to make sure that if the defect hadn't been there then the failure must not occur either.
And these are the two things we need to show when we fix a defect.
In order to make sure that the defect is an error, we must show how to correct it
and to show that the defect causes the failure,
we must show that the failure no longer occurs after we have changed it.
It is important to show both the defect is an error and the cause
in order to avoid situations in which a defect only is an error but does not cause the failure
or that something causes the failure but is not an error.
Let's look at the these. First, you can have an error that's not a cause.
Here's you, looking at your program and you look at the program and find tons and tons of errors.
Here's one, here's one, and there's one and you fix them and you think you're done,
but you don't know whether any of these actually fixes the problem
because it may well be that these errors you find that none of them actually causes the failure.
It simply means that after any fix you need to verify whether your fix actually did the trick
and better yet before the fix, you should be able to precisely predict
that your change will actually fix the failure.
The second category is causes that are not errors.
If you think of our Mozilla example for instance, we found that the select tech in the input
causes Mozilla to crash when printing, however, this is just a cause, it is not an error.
This is perfectly legal html input and at the very least some input that
Mozilla should normally be able to cope with.
In particular Mozilla should not crash on any input.
What we have here is the cause, but we haven't find the error yet.
The error is somewhere in the, code probably in the piece of code that handles the printing of select tags.
We can have errors that are not causes and causes that are not errors.
The goal in debugging is to find errors that actually caused the failure.